so let's go cheated on me
[Music]
right and
listen at the end of the day
there's still a certain level of
responsibility that i had not the fact
that she cheated on me but kind of like
the emotional turmoil that i put her
through because of my inability to
kind of like show emotions properly yeah
and with marielle she was the woman that
stuck around and broke that down out of
me right yeah it's okay for you to say
in five four
[Music]
now
so congratulations johnny depp
you won your [ __ ] case against a
psychopath well apparently like they
both won what do you mean because they
because uh amber heard countersued him
right
so um he won 15 million dollars but she
won two million dollars from what
um because one of johnny's past lawyers
from
the previous case
said that her story was a hoax
and then she won the the case that
the fact that it wasn't a hoax of a
story so she only lost 13 million yeah
but here's the thing apparently i think
if you google it she's only worth eight
million dollars
oh was that her 8 million worth is it
was from the original divorce settlement
that's what's left yeah well this is the
crazy thing right i'm not sure if i
mentioned this before but you could go
into the the whole litigation process of
them going back and forth specifically
with johnny depp's lawyer i forgot her
name
but she was
something yeah she was ripping into
amber yeah and this part was so awkward
so she was saying basically
she goes so you didn't
um donate
all of your
divorce proceedings to whatever the
children's foundation i forgot which
charity it was it was the aclu yeah aclu
yeah who in fact wrote the first draft
of that [ __ ] op-ed apparently yeah
yeah yeah and that attached her name to
it so yeah that's what's that's another
wild thing it's all [ __ ] crazy yeah
and she goes no i pledged my money did
you give the money or not you know and
then she's trying to dance around and
she goes i pledged it i wasn't allowed
to that [ __ ] went on for like four
minutes or some [ __ ] it was just so
just back and forth to the point where
the judge was like all right let's just
cut yeah next question she's just
clearly dancing around the [ __ ] yeah she
didn't donate any of the [ __ ] money
yeah well what was donated was actually
donated from elon musk
hillary amber so you know how they use
the date right before that and then
there was that [ __ ] um with that video
on the elevator with them making out and
the i never saw that you didn't see that
that's that was part of the case that
she brought [ __ ] james franco and
elon musk to johnny depp's penthouse
yeah it was and then the [ __ ] lobby
the doorman like had it in account that
there they came in and she was making up
with elon musk
yeah
yeah
listen i love elon musk but that's not a
man you should ever make out with so
unless you're trying to marry him yeah
like who the [ __ ] ever looks at elon
musk and gets their [ __ ] wet to to to
hook up with unless you're trying to
marry him hey man billionaire breath is
just as good
it's like six-pack abs right
um but
so here's my little shout out to elon
musk theory
right
so the week or day i think it was like
literally days apart
when the evidence was submitted with
this [ __ ] video of james franco on
and elon musk on two separate occasions
going up
you know to [ __ ] his [ __ ] house at
johnny dev's house the audacity
is when he announced that he was gonna
buy twitter
oh it [ __ ]
overtook the headlines of this elevator
thing
right and more people heard about james
franco but the
but the thing was yeah elon musk was in
that whole see that's the crazy thing
loved square because i remember
originally they said that they were
going to bring james franco up to either
to testify yeah but then he didn't have
to so i didn't hear about the elon i
kind of they said that they were dating
i didn't know there was like footage of
them making out in the [ __ ] elevator
dude there's like footage of
amber hurd and elon musk at home and
amber herb it hurt is like verbally
abusing him
you know elon musk weren't even together
no they were together together yeah yeah
there was a while when they were
together what was he saying to him
like it was just like down talking him
like he's a child you know and this
guy's a billionaire like genius
yeah
you're so [ __ ] dumb i mean the same
way she talks to johnny dead she was
talking to elon musk the same way
oh so she's just toxic as [ __ ] yeah yeah
i wanna i wonder what she's berating one
of the most brilliant minds in our
current situation like in our in our
century right now what the [ __ ] are you
telling him
what are you berating him about let me
tell you you're so [ __ ] dem why don't
you put gas in your electric cars so
they could i don't know go even further
you [ __ ] dumb idiot
i mean yeah she's crazy all around i
mean like the other fact is that she's
actually been arrested for domestic
violence in seattle what yeah she was in
she's bi and so she was dating a girl in
seattle and just punched her in the
[ __ ] something yeah and and amber got
[ __ ] arrested for domestic violence
like it's
like that was out there too so
yeah in the end um
yeah johnny depp
quote unquote wins even though they
technically both win but then he gets
you know 15 million well i mean there
are 13 million in the end
the interesting thing about this too is
like it goes back to i feel
you know there was that time during the
whole me too movement right and there
was a headliner before the me too which
was believe all women believe all women
that's in fact i when i was waiting in
the car right now i was scrolling
through twitter believe all women is
trending right now as a sarcastic
hashtag yeah amber heard and it's just
damn dude yeah
well you know first of all i understand
where that stem from right because the
the scale was tipped over the other way
right where
women were just they just weren't
believed at all they're like oh what
they were victim blaming he's like what
were you wearing that night were you
wearing a skirt why didn't you close
your legs like um you know didn't you do
this or that why did you go to his house
wearing a skirt unless you didn't want
to get [ __ ] it would be
those type of terrible terrible
conversations that would happen which uh
which is the reason why the you know the
hashtag believe all women or you know
came about which i understand but when
you say something that blank why is it
so binary yeah i just saw black and
white
what the [ __ ] and you know and then all
these dudes started coming out i was
like yo hold on a second yeah i have
plenty of stories of where women try to
take advantage of me
i've been like abused i've been verbally
abused
what is this idea of believe all women
yeah we should take into account but you
can't throw away [ __ ] hard evidence
yeah just because
this this moment of believe all women
came out which i and which makes sense
yeah right so i mean this is what
happens to somebody like johnny depp
where
you know this this op-ed came out and
automatically johnny depp is a [ __ ]
monster yeah there was no thing of like
okay well let's see the evidence let's
see what johnny depp passes say they're
just they just go straight to he beat
the [ __ ] out of amber heard he's a
terrible [ __ ] human being which
albeit the man did a lot of coke yeah
you know
he looks like prime suspect number one
yeah he's kind of permafried yeah he has
literally become jack sparrow like now
yeah
he looks a little funky he looks like he
might beat a couple of people every now
and then
but that's not evidence but he but he
admits to all of his faults if you're if
you're watching yeah
yeah
he says
all everything about his drug problems
how terrible detoxing is um how
uh the the situation of of uh all the
times he's angry he admits to all of
that stuff
you know and which is pretty much why
amber heard you know wins the hoax
because if the lawyer says it's a hoax
and then he's on the stand saying yeah i
get angry you know yeah but then um he
absolutely denies ever like hitting her
um but anyways going back to the whole
hashtag thing like believing all women
it's
being so binary
i don't think any guy
here could say believe all men
because even guys no don't believe every
guy you meet yeah for real i don't
believe any dude
don't trust anyone yeah yeah i think uh
i think but that is the disparity in the
mindset of these two phrases when we say
it like when you say believe all men it
is kind of ridiculous yeah but then when
you say believe all women at a very
vulnerable time you know in that
movement then like yeah it got spread
like wildfire
without people thinking hey uh
like everyone well yeah listen listen to
the stories and i'm pretty sure
everybody has an example
of where you saw a situation a certain
way and somebody else saw a situation
another way and in between both these
stories there was the actual truth
and we see that a lot right and
even with like personal drama like i've
had like last year too
i had to go through this whole series
where i had to you know cut out a few
people but then you hear from like other
people around they have their versions
of the story that other people heard
through the other person and they
immediately just go off and they go oh
and i've been confronted like oh so what
happened between you and ex person yeah
and i tell them the story and they go oh
your sounds a little bit more believable
i'm like
well yeah how come you never asked me
yeah right the evidence will always
speak for itself right so we had to cut
out
you know a person in our lives um small
group of friends and we just had to cut
this person out
because he was being very
he's always been like a piece of [ __ ]
well you keep describing because i'm
still trying to guess what you're
talking about yeah
i'll tell you after yeah but he's always
been like a piece of [ __ ] and then we've
always
i i kind of went against my initial
instincts and usually with my gut
instinct whether i'm right or wrong i
kind of stick to it and then i just see
what happens after so when i first met
this person years ago
i
didn't like this person generally off
the jump right we didn't really vibe
very well and then when we went on this
uh this like trip together i really got
to see this person's true colors
specifically we were in a foreign
country where you know there is that
that stigma that american people have
when they go to another country they
treat it as if it's america
this person was that definition to the
[ __ ] t right the entitled tourist the
entitled [ __ ] tourist and so when
we're in this country when you're in
like the subway system right it's asia
like you're supposed to be a little bit
more quiet and pulled back
and uh specifically in this country
you're not supposed to eat while you're
on the subway right it's against it's
literally against the rules like you'll
see it and [ __ ] was like i'm
giving [ __ ] i'll do whatever i want it
starts eating in the subway i'm like
[ __ ] this person
entitled and just
by the way the worst quality about this
like any time we were together
especially because they were a couple
they would [ __ ] scream and fight
and yell each other in front of us all
the time
constantly fighting 24 [ __ ] seven and
the way they would the things that they
would say to each other was [ __ ]
crazy everywhere we [ __ ] went and but
then as time progressed i gave them
chances and opportunities well
eventually that [ __ ] dried up because
they did some [ __ ] crazy shady [ __ ]
cut this person out and lo and behold
starts bad-mouthing us to uh to all
these other people but the one common
denominator is how is the fact that
everybody in this group
kicked you out yeah and everybody in
this group says the same thing about you
but you're the only one that says
different stories about everybody
you're the problem yeah and if you look
into their past they don't have any of
their friends from the past and the only
time they bring up friends from their
past it was so funny like they started
hanging out with their old friends from
back in the day
after we left them yeah and then all of
a sudden you start hearing stories about
saying like oh oh these people are my
best they they've always been down to
ride with me funny thing is it's like if
i met one of them i would tell them oh
did you know that they called you a
loser
they said that you're the reason why
they've never been able to get out of
their shitty situation um because they
were hanging out with people like you
and that you're you're the reason why
they were never able to elevate
themselves until they met us
did you know that they said that about
you
right yeah doesn't know any of that
stuff yeah but you know just for like
outside appearances they want to go
ahead and make sure that oh i've i was
wronged
but you know like i said it's
immediately believe that person's story
but when you know people start talking
to me one one-on-one or the other people
they go oh that story makes a little
more sense because i never really said
anything terrible about them i just said
hey
things didn't work out um
they grew to be different people than we
thought
i wish them all the best yeah them on
the other hand badmouthing the [ __ ] out
of all of us it's like
why the [ __ ] do you do that
yeah right because if you wanted we
could make this a problem i can go to
every person that you were talking [ __ ]
to and we could sit in a circle if we
sat in a circle right we had a
conversation and we brought every
[ __ ] person around that you were
talking terrible things about us to
would you be able to say that same thing
and corroborate that story you wouldn't
be able to yeah you're behind the safety
of no contact
exactly and the hard part about the
relationship already being over it's
because the uh i've realized these type
of people like unless you really are
that truly conniving um most people
really don't know that they're
writing their own story or making their
own narrative where they're going to
come out on top as a good person almost
to the point where they feel like they
have to tell the story out loud to so
many people so they can believe it they
believe it yeah oh i i i thought you
were this i thought you guys were
like it was this way and then but then
because
it's not like they care that much it's
just they hurt it one way and it's like
okay i guess that's the way it is yeah
you know and like like listen like
changing stories is so [ __ ] hard i
get caught up all the time because every
time i tell a story from my past i'm
trying to be careful enough to where i
don't tell too much information where it
can lead back to these people because
i'm from a small town and i've said this
multiple times before and so like
certain details will change but the
heart of the story is the same and the
reason why that happens is because i
have to change these details and it's
going to change a little bit here and
there because it's supposed to be for
comedy a funny story sometimes things
are exaggerated a lot of the times
the other time is because
i just don't want this information to go
ahead and [ __ ] up these people's lives
yeah so these guys that are girls
sometimes they're not sometimes the guys
sometimes they're girls it'll flip
around yeah the names are never the
[ __ ] same because i don't remember
what i called them before but i'm just
trying to be mindful enough to where i
don't out these people you know what i'm
saying my lovely genius farts this
podcast is brought to you by longtime
sponsor better help my friends life can
be so overwhelming and many people are
burned out without even knowing it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless or trapped attachment
fatigue and so much more i don't know
how many times i can tell you how much i
love better help but i know it's helped
a lot of people who have been listening
to this podcast because i've been
getting messages consistently that they
have been working on their mental health
and has become an important part of
their life and that's why they feel
better i know there's a weird stigma
about it but i've been going to therapy
for a long time and i'm no perfect
person and when i'm stressed out i need
better help guess what better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with the therapist in under 48 hours
genius brain listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
genius that's better h h-e-l-p
dot com slash genius so i understand
like when these people try to tell their
stories they always spin this new story
and they don't know how to back it up
again because they don't know what the
[ __ ] they're saying yeah i mean
it ties into obviously a lot of uh our
insecurities about what people think
about us
right but then um that goes to show like
they
don't want to lose control
you know of what people think of them as
well
you know um
you know like i said nobody wants to be
a bad guy but then it prevents us from
actually knowing where we [ __ ] up yeah
and growing and being the better person
we think we want to be yeah right or we
say that we are
right i mean the first sign is really
like you gotta know when you [ __ ] up
yeah and the crazy thing is is you know
when sometimes things don't work out
especially in terms like relationships
senses with like friendship
i don't have an objective after we split
to go ahead and destroy your name
you know
my thing is you just go the [ __ ] your
way
and then we'll go the [ __ ] unless they
did something crazy like that's super
damaging to my reputation then i have to
rectify it yeah right but other than
that
you go live your life and i'll i'll go
ahead and live mine yeah but
like i said the the biggest sign that
i've always seen from other people who
have gone through this situation is i
look at the person who goes around town
just talking [ __ ] about this person
constantly and the other person is just
like
okay
if yeah if you see someone else more
stoic about the situation
like um perhaps they're not just a piece
of [ __ ]
yeah perhaps they don't you know they're
they're walking above it yeah you know
that maybe it's worth asking them you
know yeah
it's weird like i and i always felt bad
too where especially for me i kind of
like hated myself because i should have
just followed my instinct but against my
better judgment i kind of listened to
other people in the group and they were
like look this person is really [ __ ]
cool yeah don't worry it was just that
one situation but i saw these terrible
habits for so many [ __ ] years this
sense of entitlement um just constantly
verbally bashing people behind behind um
everybody's backs like so this person
would do this thing where
in front of you they would be like oh
saying all these great things about you
but they will go to somebody else in the
group and then talk [ __ ] about you all
that [ __ ] catches up we all we all
[ __ ] picked up the pieces yeah we're
like oh you have to leave this [ __ ]
group now you're you're in such close
proximity with one another like where
did you think this was gonna end yeah
yeah
i'm pretty sure everyone was gonna catch
oh this person's straight up had like
[ __ ] bpd too because it was like
nothing was ever their fault right
everything was it was victim blaming
constantly it's like i ended up this way
because of this person oh it's because
of this oh because of my husband why
fiance whatever
[ __ ] uh that's that's the reason why
this happened or it's also because
you're a piece of [ __ ] your [ __ ] self
and you haven't [ __ ] fixed any of
these issues so if the common
denominator throughout your whole life
in the [ __ ] whatever x amount of
years you've been living is the fact
that everybody has done you wrong most
likely it's probably you yeah if you
have
constantly left friend circles your
whole [ __ ] life and all these people
were toxic right even when you thought
you were bettering yourself you kept on
running into multiple circles of bad
people maybe it's your choices
maybe you're making the bad choice maybe
you're the reason why why is it that
everybody else in that circle is
successful but you yeah
it might be you and i just got i get i
think as we get older too we get so
annoyed of these habits because we don't
have
as you get older you realize you don't
have much time left on this earth why
should we have to deal with this [ __ ]
yeah why do i have to be friends with
this person because my other friends are
cool with them or why do you have to
teach them anything yeah
that's a big one why do i have to be the
[ __ ] take them aside and teach them
how to be a [ __ ] decent human being
you know what i mean
like figure that on your own it's not my
responsibility man i [ __ ] hate that
[ __ ]
i mean especially if you absolutely
cared about that person there
then you would be that
person in their lives to have told them
hey this is
where you're [ __ ] up but then it
happens you know because of whatever
they the household they grew up in it's
um you know they were never seen
or shown anything better empathy only
goes so far you know we talk a lot about
empathy and i think empathy is very
important like when you get to
understand somebody's story and it
encapsulates kind of their behavior um
whether it's good or bad and it gives
you you know kind of an understanding of
where they're coming from yeah it helps
you manage your relationship with them a
lot better but even then that has a
[ __ ] limit
like
i can understand why you are the way
that you are but i don't have to be
around to deal with it yeah right like
like the the johnny depp and amber hurd
case amber her might have had a terrible
living like growing up she might have
had a terrible life i don't know what
her family relationship's like i don't
know if she's been like sexually abused
verbally abused whatever that allows her
to do this type of behavior
but does johnny depp have to be here and
take that [ __ ] abuse does he have to
take this court case and say you know
what you're right i beat you just so she
could feel better yeah absolutely not
yeah like the
the
forensic psychologist i believe
or some one of the psychologists had
diagnosed her with bpd right
and then um
all over on social media like people
were saying like
you know opening up saying i have bpd
but there's no excuse to treat people
like this like there's no excuse for
this behavior you know either like with
the kind of resources she has
like there are you know therapies and
and manageable like worksheets to to to
work through all these kind of things
and like the hardest thing about people
with like bpd is getting them to
recognize that this is a problem
right um talking to a therapist buddy of
mine and she was telling me like her
like people with bpd actually need a
spec like a specialist because it's it's
hard yeah
there is no part in the conversation
where you could just talk to them and
they come to this realization if you get
because the moment even when a therapist
who is in the position to go ahead and
give you whether it's advice or kind of
help you sort out your thoughts they're
always in a position of like i'm never
at fault yeah so
what happens when the therapist will
come in
is that they'll you know talk them
through their problems and help them try
to navigate but the moment they feel
like they're being quote unquote
attacked they shut down and yeah oh
you're you're against me too yeah
it's because um
it is
a sensitivity disorder
everything is personal now here's the
thing
i believe michael jordan has bpd hey i
see that but he manifested he manifested
it into championships yeah because his
dad made him feel like he was never
enough yeah until he won those
championships you know
that's such a great example let me tell
you this right have you ever seen that
video online of that guy saying like
when you marry a girl everything is your
fault and he's
she rings the doorbell and like a
mosquito comes and she gets freaked out
and she looks at him she goes jonathan
i didn't see that that [ __ ] cracked me
the [ __ ] up but
that is an example of i mean that's kind
of just a funny example right yeah
that's like a a light example of like
bpd everything is a personal attack yes
so just in that case the same couple
right we went to a wedding together
and dealing with them was very hard and
i'm you know i like to keep the peace so
i just kind of like go along and i try
to ease their conversations or whatever
um they're in a van
and we're all an event we're about to
leave this wedding of a mutual friend of
ours a [ __ ] beetle flies in right
beetle flies into the van it's comes out
the person's fiancee swats the bug away
right
that person looks at their significant
other and goes are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh god and this is in front of their kid
this guy like literally did a mr miyagi
yeah he goes are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
right and i'm like
what the [ __ ] uh what the [ __ ] he goes
why the [ __ ] would you swat that [ __ ]
towards me as if the person did it on
purpose yeah and i'm sitting there just
boiling i'm seething because
the idea that you could say that in
front of number one your kid
and then on top of that to your
significant other while other people
around is such a high level of
disrespect it was it was hard for me to
swallow yeah like why
did he deserve that kind of humiliation
yeah you know i i'm looking at this and
i'm like
imagining [ __ ] danielson in karate
kid having bpd
and yeah mr miyagi catching a flight
with this chopstick yeah like are you
[ __ ] reported like yeah
like i don't know what you're like
taking it personally attack against them
dude that's yeah
to go out of your way and do that and
humiliate somebody in front of other
people and you know by the way that's
whether you're doing this in private or
public is unacceptable you know what i
mean
like unacceptable
and so you know mario 2 doesn't really
know these people yeah because they were
a part of my life before male came
around and she was just
dumbfounded yeah like what i believe one
of the
traits of ppt is
uh vigilance
right but like an impulsive vigilance so
she jumped at
doing what she felt personally was
justice to her was to humiliate this man
in front of everybody that loves him
yeah
which is so like damn that's cold their
relationship got so bad to the point
where like even the guy started
developing bad habits because he's so s
so like yeah like scared of this person
that
ended up just lying about everything
because it's right he comes back right
yeah because you're so afraid of getting
in trouble all the time so this person
started developing bad habits that made
us hate this person too because now
you're a habitual liar too yeah so it's
just this toxic [ __ ] relationship so
it rubbed off on like when he felt like
he was in trouble with you guys but you
guys probably didn't even give a [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] yeah dude even as much
as we've tried to help
because they've asked for help it didn't
matter because when we had these
conversations it was never
hey can you help our relationship out
it's can you help the person that i'm
with this person's a [ __ ] up yeah and
it's like actually
you're kind of a [ __ ] up yeah and a lot
of the behaviors that this person has
because the way that you treat them so
maybe you should probably reevaluate
what both of you guys are doing and then
come together and then see what's going
to happen but even then when we said
that guess what happened republican
number one right now it's them against
you yeah what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] do
you know why the [ __ ] do you ask them
yeah why the [ __ ] did you ask
those type of people now are completely
cut out of my life and i think like
because we grew up in a church system
when we see somebody who's hurting or
somebody that we you know supposedly
care about we want to help them yeah but
the the the downfall of that is that
their problems become yours
and because it's not technically your
problem you can't fix or solve it for
them yeah and so you just get dragged
constantly and then all of a sudden from
somebody who's trying to help them
because of his advice that they ask for
you somehow become their enemy
what do they do they become like an
energy vampire
because all they do is
like complain but with zero solution or
knowing you have no solution and it just
drains the [ __ ] out of everyone
especially them because they're not
getting a solution but it's like why are
you asking it for something that's
completely depleted yeah you know funny
once you know when i when i cut people
out you cut them out [ __ ] completely
you don't think about them you don't
really talk about them right obviously
this is a podcast so we're bringing it
up in conversation
but um
a buddy of mine told me they're like
dude
did you know that that person [ __ ]
posted a photo of their mom and
that person and their mom they've been
open about how much they hate their mom
right
abandonment issues or whatever and then
he was telling me the title was like
this person has always been my day one
has never left my side i love my mom
it's like dude you're a [ __ ]
psychopath
and it's literally a few days after we
cut them off it's like man dude you
can't help these people man
it's super [ __ ] hard so like what
what do you do man and i'm pretty sure a
lot of people who are listening now
like if you recognize this type of
behavior with people in your group i'm
telling you right now cut them cut them
out you're not going to be able to help
them because they don't want to help
themselves they're perfect in their mind
they're perfect they're never wrong well
i mean it ties into
like a cognitive thinking kind of
behavior pattern right where
um
when they're faced with trauma
in front of them it's fight or flight
right
and
well whatever mechanism that they find
right they
they have to
come up with a story
to
explain what is going on around them
right so they create their own reality
literally
and to them this is their truth no
matter what
by the way that was that person's
favorite phrase their truth this is my
truth yeah well there's the objective
truth objective truth you [ __ ]
psychopath yeah
and then
because they are constantly
faced with opposition
right and you could say an existential
threat
they will double down
in their toxic extremist extremist
ideology of their truth yeah their truth
then they will double down which creates
a bigger and bigger
hole if you would say right
and everything i'm saying right now is
the entire plot to wanda vision
that was her whole thing right with
wanda was like she couldn't face the
fact that vision was gone yeah you know
and like this home they were supposed to
build wasn't there and out of her
immense grief
that she was faced with her powers she
created her own reality right in order
to maintain it she had to keep expanding
and expanding it and force her will and
her thought of her reality onto the
people around her all around her her
whole existence right i mean that's why
wanda vision to me is great because it
totally touched on the way people deal
with grief in a superhero manner with
their superhero powers dude yeah anyways
just going back to it but like that's
what people do that's what people do
yeah i mean i think it's easier for us
to pretend like we're a victim than
rather than deal with the fact that we
were the problem yeah right and
i've definitely had a lot of those
moments when i was younger right
specifically in
relationships right i'll give you a
great [ __ ] example there was a girl
that i was with she was a crane run you
know you you knew where she was she when
it was when we were living in an
apartment 904 yeah yeah
so this girl cheated on me
right and
listen at the end of the day
there's still a certain level of
responsibility that i had not the fact
that she cheated on me but kind of like
the emotional turmoil that i put her
through because of my inability to
kind of like show emotions properly yeah
and with marielle she was the woman that
stuck around and broke that down out of
me right yeah it's okay for you to say
um i love you more than just once or
every [ __ ] blue moon yeah right and
for me it was like this idea it was this
defense mechanism that i built up maybe
hypothetically would have done something
to him if i had asked yeah that's how
angry i was right
but i remember after that moment where i
was so [ __ ]
just pissed off screaming at the top of
my lungs i had this moment where i saw a
mirror right not an actual mirror but
where i saw my reflection i was like
you're a [ __ ] clown bro
like how dare you let this person like
control your emotions right yeah
whatever they did happen now you need to
figure out what you're going to do well
we ended up staying together for like
another month or two but i broke up with
her after because i couldn't reconcile
the fact that she cheated on me yeah
right and it was hard but then after we
broke up i had this moment where i was
like i had to think why
why did she cheat on me i'm not a
perfect human being clearly yeah so what
did i do and i had to look back at
things and i was like you know what it
was it was her trying to get my
attention because i wouldn't give her
the attention that she honestly in a in
a committed relationship she deserved
so for example it it you know when we
had a conversation it stemmed from this
idea so
um i have a friend named uh julie julie
zahn yeah right she's a whole [ __ ]
bag and a half like shut up and dance
yeah shut up and dance she loves and
hates me at the same time right
we had that kind of weird relationship
so
i used to have like a slight crush on
julie back in the day right because she
i remember the first day that i met her
she had this tight little red dress this
cute little fat ass there's this tiny
little korean girl a chinese girl yeah
and i was hitting on her [ __ ] hard
right
um
got to know her i was like yuck
should have kept your mouth shut no
we ended up becoming really good friends
yeah so before um i got together with
this girl i specifically told her i was
like hey years ago i had a crush on
julie right i didn't have to do that but
i like being honest yeah and i said
but clearly i don't
you know what i mean yuck
so
and they're friends
right they knew each other because they
had their mutual friend was her sister
right and so i said hey are you okay
with if we still and by the way because
our friendship was
we never saw each other that often we
saw each other for projects and work
when we would act together but you know
listen if
this woman who i'm with and i'm somebody
who's you know very monogamous i'm
dedicated to the person i was like
listen if you want me to stop talking to
her i can have a conversation with her
and say hey because i used to have
feelings for you she doesn't feel
comfortable with us hanging out together
so
you know for now as we figure this out
and we kind of establish our
relationship maybe we shouldn't talk i
gave her that option she goes no i love
her i trust you i trust her it's great
so there was a day that my brother and
julie came over right yeah
and julie and i we [ __ ] crack each
other up and my brother we're laughing
our ass off and then she came into town
because she was originally she was uh at
a
pharmacy school out in stockton yeah
she comes in flies in and julie is there
i tell her by the way this is the first
time i saw julie that whole year yeah
one time and then i was like hey you
know my girlfriend's coming in and
they're mutual friends it's like you
want to just stay back and then you know
hang out and we'll get dinner together
she goes dude oh [ __ ] yeah and so we're
having dinner or whatever and one of the
things that i noticed that was very odd
that day was that um
my girlfriend at the time was holding on
to me really tight
was like kind of
like putting her hands in my back pocket
of my pants
like kind of like possessive which was
very unlike her and i was like hey stop
and she said in korean she goes where
and i was like this is a little weird
you know she's never done that type of
stuff so we went to the grocery store to
go ahead and buy it we're gonna buy like
drinks and some whatever and then kick
it back at the apartment
and all of a sudden she goes hey i have
to go i have to leave and i'm like oh
why she was my mom wants to have dinner
i was like cool i was like uh we're
gonna see each other tomorrow she goes
yeah of course so i give her a kiss
goodbye and she leaves
so a few months later where you heard
the [ __ ] fight happen that night she
went to go see another guy
to piss me off
to get back at me
because
your
brother and julie came over yeah and
once again
julie wasn't we weren't one on one yeah
there are other people there right
i'm clearly being respectful and i'm
very very communicative
and then the other thing that happened
after that i think was her last straw
was like she went to vegas right and i
had this thing of like
i think back in the day i didn't want to
feel like a needy guy because my very
first girlfriend i was profusely just
oozing over her and i think like what i
thought was that because i did that i
pushed this person away so i was very
mindful about giving people their
personal space
so
when she went to vegas to go see her
friends all i said was hey text me when
you're there and have fun you don't have
to message me just let me know when
you're when you're when you're back home
in her mind she wanted a boyfriend to
ask her how she was doing are you okay
are you safe yeah i never did that
because i didn't want to be the pushy
boyfriend right right right and she was
she wanted she wanted one she was a
little hurt that i didn't care enough to
go ahead and check in on her but because
of my past trauma yeah i decided not to
do stuff that wouldn't have been pushy
it would have just been really kind to
ask how my girlfriend is doing in vegas
right but in my mind i'm like i trust
you i had trust issues when i was
younger because i was the jealous
boyfriend i don't ever want to be that
person again so you know
taking that you know just to go back
full circle i had to take on the
responsibility to say even though i was
cheated on it wasn't right there were
certain things that i did in my behavior
that allowed this to happen because of
my past trauma yeah i chose
not to do things that made her feel safe
and comfortable as a girlfriend yeah and
that was hard for me i had to sit there
and be like
and i know like certain people be like
you being [ __ ] on is never your fault
to a certain extent no right that
person's behavior is that person's
behavior but i did play it a part in
creating insecurity in this person and i
could have dealt with it a lot better
you know
i mean i i think a lot of people would
argue that it is your fault especially
in this situation exactly but i mean um
only a a cognitive person would be
inclined to see
you know where their
um responsibilities came in yeah this
relationships it's a two-way street
right it takes two to tango here it's
not like
everything is always one person's fault
and that
is going back to the idea of people
having to create their own narratives
you know that's not scary you should do
yeah it just the story doesn't make
sense if it's so one-sided wait you know
like how did this happen that way like
what is the reason that's like this
person is so terrible it's like well why
does this person have so many friends
how can people say great things about
them but you yeah so so what's really
going on here how is it that eight other
people cut you cut you out but they're
all still friends but you're not it's
like they're trying to paint a picture
of you but they're using all the wrong
colors yeah and they keep telling the
same story so they can believe it
themselves right yeah and then for me
for that friend i always like
it's not i'm not saying this to feel
better about myself right i genuinely
feel bad for people who can't
just
step outside of their own body and say
what am i responsible for because for
the rest of your life you're always
going to be a victim yeah and it's
continuous cyclical behavior because you
were saying even as a tight-knit group
this person would talk [ __ ] and then
obviously it would go around right it's
like obviously they're gonna hear it but
then even though you guys don't go
no contact and you guys are apart from
each other but then you guys still have
many mutual friends yet that behavior
continues continues and i don't say a
single bad thing about like this is the
thread that it's going to get it's going
to get back to you yeah right especially
because they already heard my story
after they com they confronted me
because you know like they're straight
up and they understand that i'm straight
up too so i was like listen if you feel
that certain way about me or you don't
like me let me tell you my side of the
story and guess what if you hate me for
it hey bro don't waste your time with me
you know be that person's friend right
and there's a couple of people who felt
that way and guess what happened they
stopped being their friend wow because
they thought
because every time they would meet up
that person would talk [ __ ] about that i
was the center of their subject not just
me but the other people
they would const like every time and
they came back like dude every time we
hang out with her
all they do is just talk [ __ ] about you
and i was like and you only say good and
by the way for me
i would only say good things about them
because i don't
i don't want that person to live in
misery because if that person is happy
my life becomes happier because if
they're happy with their life they don't
[ __ ] up mine
you know
right
so this person gets to live in joy yeah
they won't be so [ __ ] i don't know
they wouldn't have so much angst towards
me dude way to go wayman dude kindness
kindness is your weapon yeah right it's
his strategy
when when uh going back to that uh move
everything everywhere all at once is
we're talking about waymon has that
that moment when evelyn chooses kindness
she
um hears weymouth out at the movie
premiere right
and that's when he starts doing his
monologue about how kindness has become
his strategy his weapon to keep the
peace
you know and to make the compromise and
to get what he needs what he wants in
the end you know what's crazy too it's
like just the other day somebody a
mutual friend of ours asked like so you
know what happened to you between you
and this person i said listen you don't
need to know the details but if you want
to stay their friend
say their friend you know they have a
lot of great qualities they've been
through a lot of stuff so just manage a
relationship with them and you know
don't get too involved like i did but if
you keep it like that you'll have a
great [ __ ] time but just know that
they have a lot of baggage and if they
start opening up to you
um just know that take it take it with a
grain of salt and so yeah i mean
god bless you dude you're like giving
this person like all of the mileage to
grow right like they've got a journey
ahead of them like a lot of people and
their mental health you know they they
do everyone's on this marathon right
what the crazy [ __ ] is though after i
said that just to complete that part
[ __ ] came back to me a couple
days later like [ __ ] this person
i was like what happened they're like
all they do is just [ __ ] talk about
how bad the life is they talk [ __ ] and i
look at their posts and they're talking
about how happy they are i can't deal
with this i was like hey
if you want to be a good friend be there
for them right like i said just have fun
with them and once they start opening up
about their personal stuff they're
trying to drag you into their misery
take them for what that what it is the
moment you engage in that type of
friendship relationship with them is the
moment you lose they're actually very
fun people
but
only at a distance yeah don't get too
close because you might get burned
unless you're willing to take on that
baggage well i won't even lie dude like
a lot of the things that you say like
you know like i recognize myself like
the bad behaviors
you know and and then i can look back
like you said about how you had to take
a step back and look at your hand in the
game and that by the way that is hard
because yeah
i think when you judge yourself it hurts
your feelings more and you start to kind
of beat yourself up you go [ __ ] did i do
this
why did i do that and i somehow had to
like sit there and say fix this behavior
or it's going to continue in your future
relationships like i said thank god for
[ __ ] muriel because for her i mean
obviously she has a lot of flaws too but
she yeah let's get that in first but
okay let me just say that all right hey
i love her but it's only fair you ain't
perfect yeah you know but
she kind of poked at me in the right way
to say like hey
this is not a good behavior and you're
gonna have to fix this and i it's like
behaviors that i knew but nobody told me
that yeah you know and so when she said
it it's like listen if i want to be with
her not just her or with anybody else
i have to fix this here yeah because
i'll carry it on to the next
relationship not being able to like
emotionally say hey i love you you look
pretty today give you gifts and flowers
when i feel like i want to because i'm
afraid that at the end of the day if i
do this for you you still might leave me
i got to fix this now yeah it's going to
carry on to the next relationship you
know
i mean uh just bringing it back to how
um i i said earlier about how we really
have to rather than
creating this false reality around us to
tell a narrative to
justify our actions even though we know
we did something wrong
right the the first step is to
acknowledge like where you made a
mistake yeah and to be okay with the
mistake you've made
right because um what's the first
most important thing you know is that
you have to forgive yourself
which is hard mistakes it was a crazy
hard i mean i struggle with that all the
time
like sometimes when you look back you
just go
sometimes like in my head people don't
know this
but i'll be like you [ __ ] yeah
dude
you dude
i'm not talking about daily yeah daily
why did you say that yeah
i mean because it it happened
and i mean as much as we're thinking
about that it's like well that was in
our past the the first sign of cringing
at yourself yourself knowing it's you
is that you're no longer that way
you know
and
and you have to come to the point when
you find yourself cringing at yourself
which i do a lot
you know is to you know
understand that you're feeling this way
because this was a past version of
yourself yeah yeah right it might have
been 10 years ago it might have been
yesterday as long as today you know i
[ __ ] up
right and that's one of the most
important things for me too like a lot
of my trauma i i deal with in the
obsessiveness i have with ah this person
[ __ ] me this person [ __ ] me so hard
right and and i get so mad at that but
then i have to look at like you did you
know where where i was in the picture
right maybe i was an [ __ ]
you know maybe that was why they were so
hard-nosed with me and they did some
[ __ ] to me right
uh maybe there was like a lot of things
i did that never
made this relationship actually be a
positive one right
um
at least
when you can acknowledge that and
understand what happened to you in the
past
you can walk into a new relationship and
start something new and know not to [ __ ]
up in these areas yeah
unless you want to tell your own story
and say you were right all along and
then you [ __ ] do the same [ __ ]
mistakes the same behaviors the same
fuck-ups
it's because you keep creating that
narrative for yourself that you're the
good guy you know i think like we should
make it clear too we're not talking
about blaming yourself like victim
blaming right
that's not the conversation it's more
like what can i do better next time so
that doesn't happen again yeah right and
that's the level of personal
responsibility that you have like even a
lot of the stories that i would tell
where i got [ __ ] over there's a lot of
stuff i could have done differently i
don't dwell on it but then once i take
that responsibility it makes it makes me
make sure that i won't make that same
mistake again can i tell you a story
yeah
i've been like pissed at
this guy we know
who is
a singer on youtube
and
um they were asking me about editing or
because they at the time this is old
youtube um they sing covers you know and
every week it's just another cover right
and
nothing changes with their camera angles
ever yeah and so i gave them a
suggestion and i showed them an old
video
of mine like showing look this is also a
video of a guy just singing on a mic
just like this
and there's just
like one mid and one close-up yeah you
know um
but
what was interesting in the video that
made it different though was that this
at the time that i was so angry when i
was filming this this [ __ ]
didn't know the words to this song he
was singing jesus christ i [ __ ] hate
that when i show up to a shoot and then
whoever is singing even especially if
it's their own [ __ ] song and they
don't know the lyrics i hate that [ __ ]
when they come unprepared that way so i
was so mad like we had no good footage
right
but then he kept asking me when the
video was coming out so i just made the
entire video
footages of him like [ __ ] up the
lyrics yeah right and and [ __ ] up the
lip sync and um it was just all the shot
super he got it wrong
right and the thing was it was pretty
endearing because he's not a bad looking
guy yeah you know and then it got a
decent amount of views so i showed him
like look you can be creative and
innovative when you only have one angle
right
that following whatever day he releases
his video
shot
for shot
cut
for cut
a copy of my [ __ ] video shout out to
jason chen
yeah it was him yeah
all right like you want to say it okay
it was look up matt becker b-e-k-k-e-r-k
he was good i don't know what happened
to that guy you fell off dude oh but it
was really good though yeah yeah but
like
i mean you can look that up
give your heart a break and then look up
jason give your heart a break
holy [ __ ] i was so [ __ ] mad and angry
and he didn't see that there was any
problem with it which was just like yo
this is
that's the weird thing about jason too
like
if you want to talk about somebody who
doesn't have ill intent but always [ __ ]
up
is that guy like i don't know if i'm
supposed to be mad at him yeah cause
like for him
he it's not
there's a reason why we're still friends
how can i how could someone use your
friend do this to you right it's like
how can i be mad at somebody who is
clearly on the spectrum
like that's exactly why
well because it's like this he'll show
you the video it's like look what i did
and he's like hold on [ __ ] but
he goes i don't get it yeah there's no
ill intent so it's like what did i do
wrong he [ __ ] like checkmates you
with that [ __ ] yeah with his autism
he goes bam
rook to your night autism
oh [ __ ] and he just you won the game
with the pawn right how'd you do that
yeah and it's
and for me too it was one of those
things where i was like well you know
what i'm never gonna share my ideas with
anyone who's not gonna pay me again
there's a lot of people who do that
though like i've i stopped listen i've
never said this out publicly but there's
a lot of people online that you know
they wanted to make vine videos right
yeah and
i've
found out early on with these wine
people and you'll see it in social media
now this is what it's evolved to that's
why you always see [ __ ] bitten off
content as people recycle and reuse and
it started with vine and so these vine
people would just be talking i would
tell them stories about my personal life
and they would put in their vine i'm
like oh
turn it into a light and they turn it
into a vine and i'm like
uh i told you that in confidence because
i told you i was gonna make a sketch out
of it yeah and so i cut ties with them
i'm like you guys steal ideas because
you ran out of your own
right you know that happened to me with
general man
this whole that's right yeah with the
average uh advertising agency that they
were with
like
i had a meeting with them shared an idea
two weeks later there's my [ __ ] idea
on social media that's why you gotta
keep things to yourself you know one of
the biggest reasons to like vlogging to
me um started
there's so many ways like i did a vlog
recently right i haven't done a vlog in
a long time but a lot of the stuff that
i leave out i leave out because i might
turn this into stand-up later i never
had that issue before and the reason why
i do that because i have seen and you
guys know it too who are mega fans of my
you guys have seen like my content i've
done in the past be turned into vines
quick content on instagram and it's
literally my [ __ ] bit for bit joke for
you yeah
yeah you get no credit right the wild
west like i had to call somebody out
years ago who literally took one of my
vlogs and did a stand-up set with it and
it was my it was it was like bro and i
found out because other people would tag
me like isn't this your vlog i was like
it they didn't even change it yeah oh my
god and by the way and by the way they
and i was so upset because they did that
[ __ ] as a stand-up set and they bombed
with it
how dare you misrepresent me
how dare you
vicariously bomb through my content i
was like the jokes are good your
delivery was terrible
how can you steal the bomb with my
content yeah if you're gonna steal it do
it well yeah
[Laughter]
dawg that [ __ ] pissed me off the
delivery was so bad
and i was like i messaged the person was
like hey bro you gonna steal my [ __ ]
[ __ ] was it another asian comic it was
another asian comic right and i actually
still see it a lot till this day you
know um
and you know what that's fine like
that's how content is now it's not fine
but well how am i gonna fight against it
yeah you know and by the way a lot of
stuff happens too in like the the comedy
world where there's like um you know we
think of the same [ __ ] but like
depending on the delivery you could tell
when they thought it was their own idea
and not right yeah but nowadays where
like content death is so common and it's
accepted it's so annoying yeah i mean
reposting is the nature of the game like
and then you don't see that [ __ ] come
back to you no matter what
all these tech companies try to do with
like i mean youtube does it all right
but dude somebody wrote on a comment and
comments usually don't make me upset but
i had to correct this [ __ ] and i
they just started rambling [ __ ] i
blocked them because i did a trump
impression they go oh look at you uh
[ __ ] uh stealing shane gillis's bit
i'm like a trump impression what
every president gets an impression
exactly and so i was because i started
watching a lot of trump [ __ ] because you
know when they were comparing biden and
trump being senile and i started picking
up like trump's mannerisms right and
shane gillis did a bit where he's
talking about the same manners but
everybody can observe the same thing
yeah
so it's like that's like me saying like
somebody comes up to me and go oh you
[ __ ] stole x comic because you
impersonated arnold schwarzenegger yeah
like you have lost your [ __ ] mind
yeah you coming at the wrong person dude
dude i heard you do
that chicken cross the road joke yeah
it's the audacity but i get it too right
but like i said everybody's just going
back and forth it's like so you could
steal content but then other times
you're going to call somebody out for
having i don't know the most general
impression impersonation of trump like
what what is this what world do we
[ __ ] live in man i think it's like i
said if if it's in the comic book it's
obvious it's a pretty doggy dog right
like from i mean i i i really enjoyed
seeing the behind the scenes of the
bobby lee brennan shop trauma dude the
whole podcast on that [ __ ] yeah
and you know
i i think you know going time back to
what we were saying earlier like
everyone has a narrative or whatever
because they need to come out on top
yeah because for some reason life is a
competition to them and if somebody for
some reason has something nice happen to
them that means you're losing
then you are looking at life in the
complete wrong way yeah man and like i
saw shane gill's i didn't see the whole
thing but i saw bishop and it was really
[ __ ] funny yeah i understand he's a
funny guy yeah he's [ __ ] funny right
then like i i was pretty incensed with
some of those yeah quote unquote so like
when i because i think the observation
that i made
i mean i have to look at the video again
i'm not gonna correct it either way i i
i was talking about how if you look at
any kind of uh
trump clip he always
says wow
wow wow that's amazing right and i guess
shane gillis did a bit where he
explained it and he put in this to his
bit but how
everybody can observe that it's pretty
obvious even you know what i was saying
when i said it yeah it's like oh it's
amazing it's like if somebody else does
an obama impersonation and you're like
hey those pauses and those intonations
you're copying so you know that's his
[ __ ] everybody hears that man
yeah i didn't i didn't really appreciate
that comment that one for some reason
got under my skin i think the idea with
why people want to like jump on
impersonations
like is such a weird paradox to me like
like you're still copying the original
person themselves you know yeah so
what's the originality in that [ __ ]
unless you like add your own twist or
spin to it you know and even um like for
example there was um
people were [ __ ] on godfrey in the
comments uh godfrey is [ __ ] hilarious
yeah and there's other comics who say
that godfrey never bombs and you know he
does this like steve harvey impressions
oh yeah i saw that [ __ ] it's just so
funny that she had me crying yeah
but um i heard steve already hated that
[ __ ] yeah
but it was accurate yeah um but godfrey
does this bit where he talks about uh
nigerian people because he's from
nigeria yeah right goshri where are you
from you know
and then he does this joke where he
shoots at dart right he goes like these
[ __ ] like where are you going
and he'll shoot somebody he passes out
well eric spears did a joke like that
too right and like you stole that [ __ ]
from eric spears first of all they're
friends number two god frees nigerians
third of all i've heard hella comics
through that dart joke yeah it's like
where are you going i i've seen that
joke even before aries spirit er eric
experience arie spears yeah like but he
did it differently like it's not the
same joke and also he's [ __ ] nigerian
yeah he's nigel you can't [ __ ] say
that to that guy if anything else
aerospears is impersonating his life
yeah
so it's like what do you do here you
know i i think it's the whole idea of
people can't take a joke
yeah like uh they see the idea of coming
somewhere to laugh instead their idea is
to [ __ ] [ __ ] on everything yeah yeah
why are you there why'd you go to the
comedy show in the first place like what
are they really saying outside of that
it's just like hey how are you
you know putting any effort into
differentiating yourself from another
korean comic
you know it's like wha why why is that
any of your concern yeah you know yeah
but like i said it's not it's not it's
like
point zero two percent of people out
there you know and i still defend their
right to go ahead and write those
comments because you know it's the
internet you can say whatever you want
yeah but i'm allowed to clap back
however the [ __ ] i want to [ __ ] and
don't go back and be like well why are
you oh you're supposed to be the bigger
person no i'm not who said
i'm not the bigger person i'm very
childish
[Laughter]
why do you assume that i'm such a good
person dude do you know how much effort
it takes into making the kind decision
you know
it's not easy it's not easy at all guys
[ __ ]
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the podcast yeah i feel like we had a
subject to talk about i forgot what it
was but
yeah there was something we're going to
talk about yeah i forget but uh anyways
uh you can find ed at park vp
right check him out on the instagram
you'll see him on the geniusbrain
podcast um jesus brains every sunday at
12 p.m make sure that you guys support
our sponsors because they pay my [ __ ]
bills click on those links check out
what they got because i love them and i
love you too and we will see you all
next time peace